de lo que quiero hablar en estos vídeos
es acerca de cómo las moléculas pueden
atravesar una membrana celular ya sea de
afuera hacia adentro o de adentro hacia
afuera y el primer tipo de transporte
del que quiero hablar que existe para
que las moléculas atraviesen la membrana
es el transporte que no requiere energía
solo se trata del movimiento de las
moléculas a favor de su gradiente de
concentración ya este tipo de transporte
lo llamamos transporte pasivo así que lo
voy a notar aquí transporte pasivo
este pasivo pasivo y es aquel que no
requiere energía solo es el movimiento
de las cosas a favor de su gradiente de
concentración y es master inscribirlo
movimiento a favor del gradiente de
concentración
sabor
gradiente de concentración ahora
imagínate que tienes esta membrana
celular que tenemos aquí y que muchas
partículas la quieren atravesar pero
esta membrana semipermeable será más o
menos permeable dependiendo del tipo de
molécula que la quiera atravesar
pensemos un poco
en las moléculas y pensemos un poco como
se pudiera difundir pasivamente a través
de la membrana si tenemos moléculas muy
pequeñas podemos decir que pueden ser
capaces de pasar por estos huecos o
espacios que hay entre las cabezas y
tróficas y luego pasar por esta cola
esta cola que tenemos aquí hidrofóbica y
por último pasará al otro lado entonces
el pequeño es bastante bueno ser pequeño
peque
es bastante bueno para la difusión a
través de la membrana específicamente es
el pequeño y se encarga sin
esto es lo óptimo lo que más ayuda para
tener una buena difusión y ejemplos de
esto son algunas moléculas como el
dióxido de carbono el dióxido de carbono
el cual es bastante bueno y pequeño para
que se pueda difundir así que imagínate
que por aquí tengo algunas moléculas de
dióxido de carbono y adentro voy a poner
muchas más voy a suponer que tengo a
mayor concentración de las moléculas de
dióxido de carbono adentro de la célula
que fuera de ella y como este es pequeño
y no tiene carga bueno justo como
aprendimos en el vídeo de difusión en un
momento tendremos más moléculas de
dióxido de carbono saliendo de la célula
que entrando en ella eso quiere decir
que más moléculas van a interactuar con
esta membrana que tenemos aquí y debido
a que no tienen carga no sean atraídas
por estas cabezas hidrofílicas de los
fosfolípidos de la membrana y tampoco
serán repelidas por ellos lo que va a
facilitar que estas moléculas se muevan
a través de esta membrana algunas podrán
pasar por la membrana de atravesarlas
y que estas colas hidrofóbicas tampoco
impidan su paso recuerda que tendremos
moléculas yendo en ambas direcciones
pero habrá más moléculas que vayan de
adentro hacia afuera que al revés
entonces las moléculas se moverán a
favor de su gradiente de concentración
el dióxido de carbono se puede difundir
bastante bien por las membranas
celulares y otra molécula que también lo
puede hacer es el oxígeno molecular el
oxígeno molecular entonces si tenemos
voy a dibujar esta vez más moléculas de
oxígeno afuera de la célula que adentro
de ella así que voy a decir que tengo
por aquí esta situación y el oxígeno al
ser pequeño y no tener carga no ser
atraído por estas cabezas hidrofílicas y
entonces va a poder pasar entre estas
cabezas las moléculas de oxígeno son
indiferentes para las cabezas
hidrofílicas y luego pasarán a través de
las colas hidrofóbicas lo cual también
va a ser bastante indiferente y así van
a poder
a través de esta membrana celular y como
el mayor concentración afuera que
adentro tendrás más de acciones
aleatorias yendo de este lado que de
este lado por lo tanto habrá más flujo
neto de estas moléculas hacia dentro de
la célula entonces estas moléculas serán
capaces de difundirse fácil y
naturalmente y por supuesto también van
a chocar un poco serán obstruidas por
estas estructuras
por todas estas moléculas de aquí que
forman la membrana celular pero al final
podrán atravesarla ahora qué va a
suceder con las moléculas que tendrán
muchos problemas para pasar así que
imagínate a partículas que tendrán esos
problemas serán cosas como los iones de
sodio los iones de sodio que tengo por
aquí o algunos iones de potasio así que
déjame ponerlo aquí
nació con un guión de potasio bueno pues
si te das cuenta estas moléculas que les
va a pasar
imagínate que tengo una mayor
concentración de sodio afuera que
adentro así que voy a ponerlo por aquí
por aquí por aquí y bueno por aquí
adentro voy a poner 123 nada más ahora
cuando intenten pasar de afuera hacia
adentro se van a sentir muy atraídas por
estas cabezas hidrofílicas que tenemos
aquí porque esta cabeza hidrofílica
debido a que tienen carga no dejarán
pasar estos iones de sodio entonces ya
no habrá manera de que los iones sigan
avanzando porque son atraídas por estas
cabezas hidrofílicas que tienen carga y
como las cuelas hidrofílicas no tienen
nada interesante para los iones entonces
esto se amontonarán en estas cabezas que
tenemos aquí se van a mantener en las
dos cabezas hidrofílicas pero no serán
capaces de migrar hacia el otro lado
entonces cosas que tengan carga tendrán
problemas para difundirse pasivamente en
futuros vídeos veremos que hay formas
para que puedan pasar
vemos cosas como canales proteicos que
esencialmente son túneles para este tipo
de cosas entonces naturalmente la
difusión para este tipo de cosas era
bastante difícil ahora que de las
partículas intermedias y se me ocurre en
el caso de las moléculas de agua y el
agua es muy importante porque las
células viven en un ambiente acuoso
están rodeadas de agua hay agua adentro
de la célula y afuera de la célula y
justo el agua es intermedia porque no
tiene carga pero si está parcialmente
cargada recuerda que el agua se forma
por un oxígeno y dos hidrógenos un
hidrógeno por aquí otro hidrógeno por
aquí al oxígeno le gusta acaparar los
electrones por lo tanto tiene una carga
parcial negativa mientras que los
hidrógenos tienen una carga parcial
positiva tienen una pequeña carga
parcial positiva y como te diste cuenta
llamamos a estas cabezas de fosfato
cabezas hidrofílicas recuerdas porque
son afines al agua entonces si tenemos
moléculas de agua
como su carga no es tan fuerte algunas
de ellas serán atraídas por estas
cabezas hidrofílicas vamos a ponerlas
por aquí pero después de varias
interacciones una se podrán pasar y
atravesar esta membrana y ya que las
moléculas de agua son lo suficientemente
pequeñas y como su carga no es lo
suficientemente fuerte solamente tienen
cierta polaridad al final podrán
atravesar la membrana no tan fácilmente
como lo hacen las moléculas de dióxido
de carbono o las moléculas de oxígeno
pero serán capaces de difundirse
lentamente también en futuros vídeos
veremos cómo está difusión se puede
facilitar como el agua puede trabajar
más fácilmente gracias a cosas como a
las acuaporinas que son canales que
atraviesan las membranas entonces así el
agua no tiene que lidiar con todas estas
cosas de aquí y claro si tienes
moléculas más grandes se me ocurre
dibujar una molécula como por aquí una
proteína como ésta pues observan que
ésta no va a poder pasar por esta
membrana celular tendría problemas
físicos para poder pasar por los huecos
sin más
que también puede tener problemas con
las partes hidrofílicas o hidrofóbicas
pero en fin espero que este vídeo te
haya dado una idea del tipo de cosas que
se pueden difundir por la membrana
celular claro hablando del transporte
pasivo ya el próximo vídeo hablaremos
acerca del transporte pasivo facilitado